il était une fois dans un royaume
enchanté une très belle princesse aux
cheveux noirs comme la nuit et à la peau
blanche comme la neige
ses cheveux ne sont pas noirs laisse
encore bowe et elle ne s'est jamais
exposé au soleil alors oui elle est
blanc miroir miroir
la plus belle de toutes
quand arrivait
un compte
tu parlais à mon prince trophée
récupérez votre royaume vous n'avez pas
le droit de gouverner ce royaume
c'est ce qu'on va voir fait là
disparaître dans les douars
qui est qui blanche neige
le prince est riche je l'épouserais et
mes problèmes financiers seront y
réussir il faut que quelqu'un la reine
on va t'apprendre
[Musique]
rennes est méchante j'utiliserai un
philtre d'amour
un amour de notre enquête que je vais
pouvoir perdre un animal et compagnie
gratuit votre marché
[Musique]
il est hors de question que je veux pas
de contre vous pas pourquoi vous êtes
minuscule nous avait pas mieux que ça
qui a entendu tellement d'histoires sur
des princes qui sauve des comptes
il faut changer cette fin
laissez vous charmer
avec les bandits vous avez gardé mais
tout part toi débrouille très bien tout
ça mais c'est vous envoûter la magie
noire par la plus magique des histoires
ils furent heureux à tout jamais c'est
exactement pour moi blanche neige
l'un de vous sait comment briser un sens
dit bonjour à notre petit copain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]